good morning good afternoon and hello
everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast
scrn affinity column chromatography for
therapeutic mab characterization
i'm alexis cross of leopards and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by roche custom biotech
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
custombiotech.roche.com
so let's get started
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
i would like to now introduce our
presenter
dr tillman slothauer senior principal
scientist at roche innovation center
for a complete biography honor presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
tillman you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
welcome to the today's seminar about
fcrn affinity column chromatography for
therapeutic antibody characterization
i am thomas lauter a senior principal
scientist from former research and early
development rush in the greater munich
area
this is a large molecular research
organization within the p red
organization
currently i'm working as at biological
technologies analytical department in
former technical development at
gemintech in south san francisco
the rush research organization
consists out of three independent
research hub within rush genentech and
sugar
as soon a project ends clinical
development the responsibility is handed
over to the late stage organization or
the technical development of therapeutic
antibodies such as manufacturing release
and ideally later on approval to benefit
all patients in a certain disease
in early research we are working in
several collaborations within academia
and industry to broader broaden our
knowledge in multiple directions in
addition to this
we're working with the developers
at rosh diagnostic for example to
develop new analytical tools
like the srm affinity column and this is
now the topic of my talk today
the portfolio of therapeutic antibodies
become has become more more complex over
the last year as you can see in this
overview
from the classical bivalent antibody
unconjugated format there are only some
left in our current controlling despite
that
all the shown molecules
do have an fc part in common
our task amended body analytical
characterization is to monitor target
binding such as fc functionality for
antibody selection monitoring a batch
release of such antibody based
therapeutics
fc functionality comprises three major
ac gamma receptor related biological
activities
which are antibody dependent cellular
toxicity called adcc
then we have antibody dependence
dependent cellular phagocytosis called
adcp
and complement dependent cytotoxicity
i want to talk about more details in
this direction because most of the form
is shown
before rfc engineered to eliminate all
mentioned activities to increase the
safety profile of different formats
on the other side
we have a very important feature of
human immunoglobulins like itg one two
three
and four
it's the average biological half-life
in human blood meaning the time of
circulation in the human body
depending on the igg subclass the
circulation will be around 21 days
and only the specific features of the
igg3 molecule
result in a fast clearance of about a
week due to zero igg competition
if we design now
a new igg-based therapeutic antibody it
is important for us to understand that
the new antibody format rules the
underlying fcrn based mechanism claimed
to be responsible for three weeks
half-life of igg
and here we see this mechanism now for
antibody recycling
epithelia and endothelial cells are in
direct contact
with all proteins and molecules in
circulation and experience a constant
unspecific uptake
to the surrounding fluids
of the ceramic fluids at
a ph of 7.4
in this mixture are also high level of
human albumin such as all the previous
described immunoglobulins
and after uptake the endosome endosome
is formed
that triggers
a lot of different events like
expression of different receptors
and acidification so the endosome gets
to a lower ph volume
reducing the ph
down to a value of 6 or even lower
results in the specific binding of iggs
and albumin to the efferent receptor at
the same time
this rescued these two serum proteins
from the degradation
in the later formed lysosome
the extreme bound proteins are
trafficked back
to the outer membrane of the endothelial
cells when the gauge comes back to a
value of 7.4
now i want to step into a little bit
more
of the igg fcm interaction
the structural details of both molecules
are well known
as may be seen by this figure
starting from this view it seems to be a
simple one one-to-one interaction
that may be
easily determined by existing
technologies
the antibody consists
out of two heavy chains and two light
chains
fcrn on the other side
of three alpha domains and the beta2
microglobulin subunit
now i want to step into a little bit
more detail
of the
interaction so by a closer look
the f3n molecule can bind to the left
side of this heavy chain
but this would be just a very simple
one-to-one interaction but the nature is
more complicated
you could have also an fcr molecule
buying from the other heavy chain side
of the antibody
but it's getting even more complex
in a ph dependent manner fcm is also
able to interact with itself and so
therefore able to dimerize and this
could happen to both sides of the sram
and therefore we have additional two new
interaction sites for antibody molecules
and
if we
want to address this now by a classical
surface plasmon resonance protein
protein interaction study
we would have different situations in
the affinity so if we have just an
isolated srn and a very low density
immobilization on the fcm surface or on
the spr surface
we would have a micro molar interaction
if we increase the density of fcn on the
surface
we have a high nanomolar interactions
and if we really have a crowded surface
with a lot of fcn and having all the
different events i explained in the
slide before then we have a very athene
low nanomolar binding interactions
and if we invert the setup we would hide
a lot of different antibody features
but
it would be perhaps a better
accessibility of the fc part to fcrm but
as we have seen
from the slide before fcm is also able
to interact with itself
and the two heavy chains are still
accessible and so therefore we have the
same situation as the inverted setup
shown above and so therefore there is
not really one single setup that can
describe the heterogeneity of this fda
interaction just by an fcr
and spr sa and so therefore there is no
current affinity value that can be
described
on the top of the already described
complexity there is also the observation
that even if we are using a very
standardized xcm
binding setup
and investigating in 11 different
antibodies that have in common that they
are all human igg 1xc parts
and they does differ in the individual
antigen binding region called cdrs
and
this should have if that's only the c
that is important for the interaction
should have a similar sensor ground
because we have standardized psa so the
immobilization level has been the same
for all of the different
studies but we see that we can really
distinguish by eye that there are 11
different molecules because they have
different on off rate features
and so therefore we wanted to see
how can we get behind this so is there
any correlation for affinity and
pharmacokinetic
and if we look at this overview of
different antibodies we see there is no
correlation for the relative binding
activity from therapeutic iggs that
could correlate to any half-life that is
described in humans and so there is
really a mismatch and we assume it's the
essay setup
so what is now the reason for this
and to shed light on this
fat differences we searched for
potential interaction sites of the
antibody to fcm
we utilized the hydrogen deuterium
exchange technology
this technology allows to cover igg f3n
bound complex in solution and only the
exposed hydrogens of the exposed amino
acid exchange with the theorem in the
buffer
the subsequential mass spectrometry
allows to highlight the area binding
that has protected the exchange
out of this it is possible to draw a map
of the oral areas for fc at ceramic
interaction like here
but also for the sub fcr interaction
like here in this area and this was not
known before
and only as after we have done this
studies we have seen there are certain
areas in the fat region of an antibody
that interacts with fcm
and
the existing methods for this seems to
be not sufficient
this brought us to the point where we
recognized that the current methods are
not sufficient to detect such
differences just with one single simple
analytical method
sure we could have done a bunch of
analytical setups
doing this for every antibody construct
in development
but this is quite intense in costs in
time
so how to find a solution now
dealing with a mixture of proteins and
different attributes is usually
addressed by chromatography
to separate by the biophysical
attributes like charge size and
hydrophobicity
what if we combine now a functional
separation and immobilize recombinant
human extreme to a column matrix
the advantage of such a technology
or column-based technology is that the
gradient that may be applied to elute
the bound antibodies really start at the
same point as here
so we bind the antibody at ph 6 to the
fcn receptor
and then we increase the ph value over a
gradient to mimic exactly this release
that is shown here that the antibody is
eluted from the column or from a column
tool
and then we can investigate in this
different features of antibody molecules
and the final sclerenophilic column
product features are now as described in
this slide we use biotinated recombinant
human fcn to immobilize this to a
streptavidin sepharose matrix
the slurry is packed into an splc column
housing
in a highly standardized quality control
process as a result we have a very sharp
symmetric and ph dependent illusion
profile in the gradient that we apply
now we wanted to test
how this new technology analyzed the
different human igg molecules
that we have investigated before we have
used an enzymatic digestion
to cleave seven different therapeutic
antibodies into the sub and the fc part
the comparison of the unfractionated
iggs
retention
showed that
in the top left picture we have a peak
in the void volume then we have the
antibody peak dilution profile and we
have an additional peak
that
shows up before
we have investigated the fractionation
of these fab prime 2 and fc part
but after fractionation we have seen
that the subprime 2 correlates to no
binding to the fcn column at all
and only the fc binds to the column
matrix to have a certain retention time
as shown here
and if we compare now the seven
different antibodies we directly see
that
the
uncleaved antibodies have very different
retention times as shown in the black
columns
and the sc part by itself has just minor
differences that are related to batch to
batch or to to run to run comparisons
but they're quite in the same range of
an illusion profile and there the sub
does not play a role anymore because
it's cleaved
let's use this correlation now to
systematically understand the subcharge
of influence
for this we have used two antibodies
that display significant difference in
clearance although they are targeting
the same protein
in
the human
bostikinumap is an antibody
that eludes at a ph before 7.4
from this fcm column and it's connected
to a half-life in humans of 22 days
real kingdom up has a half-life of only
eight days
and this antibodies alerts far too late
from the fcn column if we end
and cartilate from the stn column if we
engineered hybrids of these two
molecules
we have a correlation of the retention
time just in between
so therefore we ask the question what
else is important to understand the
correlation of antibody fcn binding
behavior and clearance
for that we have analyzed different
post-translational modifications such as
igg engineering
with the new scn column chromatography
technology and in the next slide i will
highlight you some
results that we have about methylene
oxidation aggregation and glycolation
differences
such as some of the fc engineering
results
so let's start with an affine oxidation
there are two conserved messianins in
the fc part at position 252
and 428
and some other types there's more than
these but in the usual human allotype
that is used in the rush portfolio
this is the same method as shown in here
these two methylenes are in the fcn
binding area as shown in this cartoon
and they are distributed above the two
heavy chains and if we do now
um hydrogen peroxide oxidation of these
molecules they are heavily oxidized in
these two methods but distributed above
the whole heavy chains
and
so therefore we could have a very severe
mixture we could have in total 10
different species
that are
found in an oxidized
um
unseparated preparation
and we could have the oxidized methyl in
252 under both heavy chains just at one
or no
then we could have the methionine 428 on
both heavy chains or only one
or we have could have a mixture of both
methionines in different constellations
having a total of every methionine
oxidized just the methylene 5252 on one
side and only the 428 on the other side
so therefore there are a lot of
different molecules
to be imagined out of this oxidation
and what happens if we investigate this
now in a normal spr assay setup so we
know okay there must be a quite
heterogeneous mixture
we know that our technology after
standardization is able to measure
sensitive fcn binding but
can it look after the heterogeneity so
do we see anything that allows us an
interpretation where all the different
methionines are oxidized
and what we observe from our standard
assay is for sure
it's roughly 20 percent reduced in
binding as we've shown here in this
graph
and
now we thought it should be possible to
separate these different species in the
scn column chromatography
and really it is
so we have a main peak again where we
have an illusion profile or retention
time that correlates roughly to the
unstressed sample
then we have a map oxidized pre-peg one
and in addition to this we have a
prepic2 and they're nicely separated by
peak valley peak separation
and we have used
a bigger sized fcn column
that allows us to separate these
fractions and to re-analyze them and
this i can describe in this slide
so we have the unmodified antibody one
that contains roughly
five percent refined 252 and two percent
defining 428
after oxidation exactly this antibody
contains
41 percent methionine for 252 and
28 percent methionine 428 oxidation
level and now we have done the
separation in the column and we have
analyzed the main peak the prefig one
and the prefig two
by um a human fc entrance generic mice
experiment
and by mass spectrometry to analyze
where are the methane distributed and
interestingly what we have found is
that the prepic2 consists of a massively
oxidized methionine 252 but only 42
percent of methanol in 428
for the pre-peak one it's just half of
the methylene 252 and 23 428 but also
interestingly in the main peak there are
20 428
so
allowing the interpretation that the 428
is not
separating the antibody in a different
way and also it's not
important for a faster clearance of this
pre-peak and what we can really assure
now is or or
our state
is that the methionine 252 is
responsible for
decreased binding strength to fcn and
this correlates directly to this
individual investigation with the fcm
transgenic mice
this slide now
shows a new developed online coupling of
cfcn column chromatography and native
electrospray ionization mass
spectrometry
that allows a detailed characterization
in an even faster analysis time without
intensive re-analysis after
fractionation
in addition to the previous described
separation of oxidized samples we were
able to demonstrate that the fcn column
chromatography is able to separate big
differences like antibody dimers
or aggregates and a linear correlation
to the content of the species which is
what is usually not
um
what usually cannot be applied by spr
because of the problem that if we have a
heterogeneous mixture we can't see what
is within this mixture we just see an
overall effect
on the other side the fcm column
is also able to allow a distinguishing
very subject-like oscillation variances
that only display a small structural
shift within the fc part
what is usually not to be seen for fcm
analysis because the glycolation pattern
does not really play that much a role
for sgn binding as it plays a role for
ft gamma receptor interaction so we can
completely de-glycosylate an antibody
and it would still have a decay
in a cytomorphous monkey
and but we see the longer the
glycopattern is the later the retention
time on the column so therefore we see
the column is also able to really
distinguish
very
minor structural differences that
can be observed in the eft structure
our colleagues from rush technical
development and late stage were also
able to demonstrate that this is
possible
for
to qualify the fcn column chromatography
to enable the use in a regulated
environment and to set up a non-critical
window as shown here
of antibody retention for example in the
comparability exercises you can measure
different batches and to just compare
are there plus translation modification
that really
results in a shifted fcn retention
and only if it is outside this window we
can claim this as critical because then
we know it's correlated to a clearance
a difference in clearance but if it is
within that it's just a minor
oxidation or minor posttranslational
notification that still allows the usage
of this batches in the clinic
and more details on this can be found in
the publication from florian zuma at all
from the bioanalysis paper in 2017.
for that i want to conclude now the
first findings that we have
so the fcn affinity chromatography is
new valuable analytical and preparative
tool to assess the fcn antibody
interaction mimicking physiological
conditions it is possible to assess
directly the physiological relevance of
subcharge effects on epsilon burning we
can also combine these charge influences
with another method that is called
heparin columns because then we can see
that in the play between subcharges two
fcn as we have described this in the
slides before but also independent
interactions to the glycocalyx of the
outer membrane of
endothelial cells
in addition it's possible to analyze
heterogeneous igg samples according to
their methionine 252 oxidation level
and the technology can be directly
coupled to a native electrospray
ionization mass spectrometry
such as we are able to
separate functional diamonds and
oligomers
and are able to separate them on the fcn
column
and even small differences in the c
glycosylation can be resolved by the fcn
column retention time
now i want to come over to the other
part of my talk
that it's also able to investigate in
antibody engineering
for that we have used standardized
controls that have been published in the
literature before
you can really
silence an antibody fcn binding by using
an amino acid exchange in these three
certain positions to an alanine but
this antibody afterwards does not bind
scrm at all or you can exchange it to
the famous yte mutation that allows a
stronger binding to fcn
and thereby we have an increased
affinity to fcrn
and also in our column we can directly
see the triple a mutation does not bind
at all it's diluted in the white volume
and the yte has a clear shift in the sgn
column that also correlates again to a
human fcn transgenic mice experiment as
you see here
in the past
and to explain the background of the yte
a little bit further so the ydb yte
mutation has been utilized
to be in combination with the
therapeutic antibody motor vitsu map
that has been in clinical development
until phase two
and this combination is
[Applause]
really demonstrating the potential of
screen engineering because this antibody
with the rsv targeting really provided a
half-life around 100 days
and so therefore it's the first step of
thinking about
antibodies engineered for example like
passive passive
immunization
and
the other direction is
that you can do this even further you
can engineer a much higher binding
strength to the fc part like
medium that which does what did with
some examples in c engineering but you
need to be careful in this direction
because if you engineer a stronger ph
dependent binding
then you can reduce the clearance
or increase the clearance reduce the
half-life of the molecules in use and so
if you have a very strong binding and
this mutation for example correlates to
an affinity of three nanomolar at ph six
and so this therefore this antibody will
directly clear it
and therefore we have utilized now for
our own engineering the fcn affinity
column to screen different engineerings
and mutants before we are doing an nvivo
experiment
and so therefore we can clearly see
when it's in the red area where we have
an over engineering of a newman fc that
correlates to a late retention time that
will be too strong to follow the ph
dependent binding because it's eluting
in a very high ph as we can observe over
here but there are other mutants that we
can combine as single or different
double mutations that we can clearly see
it would have the same feature like a
yte and we can combine this now with the
different subcharge features to really
see that we don't have a very strong
binder from the beginning we can just
adapt
the fc binding strength in correlation
to the front binding strength
and the overview is given here
so this allows us now to really
judge
different
molecules with different features
and to compare them with the fcm
affinity column so therefore we have a
direct insight what happens to
methionine 252 oxidation it still be
able to bind to fcl but it will be
weakened and so therefore the half-life
is measured measured lower compared to
the y-type molecule then we have
antibodies like the rear kingdom of
antibody where the binding is not
following the ph dependent binding and
we have a faster clearance and so
therefore it's going to an orange area
again and if we over engineer an
antibody like it is done for the app
decks that means that you block all
extra end binding for other iggs in the
human blood
that's a therapeutic context in
immunology then you block everything and
this is something that binds esther and
never comes off but you can also search
for the sweet spot and do this like the
yte or other mutations or find a new
notation that is in an area that really
follows the fcn dependent binding and
you can really directly judge this with
your controls in the fcn affinity
chromatography
and so therefore we can conclude that
the column are suitable to design and
select c engineering
and the chromatography measures specific
stop and fcn interaction at the same
time and you can really
do this accordingly
with
the different
analytical data that you have from your
antibodies
we have tested in addition to that that
the fcm affinity chromatography also
resolves human algorithm engineering
because this could be also a very
interesting scaffold for
molecular scaffold engineering for
therapeutics
and luckily we're able to share this now
with the overall research community
because we have made together with rush
diagnostics and custom biotech this
column for sale
and
therefore i'm happy to answer all your
questions
in the end
if you have
specific features that you have measured
with your own samples
and um so therefore it's the same column
type as we are using now in research and
we are really glad that we have now also
this supply from custom biotics for
ourselves because it's really beneficial
to have the highly quality controlled
standardized fcn column chromatography
as this is a product now
and therefore i want to thank all the
team members from the fc receptor
platform
that the team growth growth over time to
a very significant amount of people and
it's distributed around the world and
all the different research that we have
done is really a lot of collaboration as
i
showed you in the first slide that we
from rush period are collaborating a lot
with academia and industry thank you for
your attention
thank you tillman for that informative
presentation
so we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question is
you talked about uh
uh methionine oxidation
can you expand a little on the value of
using the column for oxidation
sure sure thank you for this question um
so in the beginning it was really
critical for us to
get the borders of mefine oxidation
announced because
this is something common for therapeutic
antibodies that they are getting
oxidized over storage and there's just
where to set the border and having now
the fcm columns in place and seeing that
is the statistical distribution of the
methionine on the two heavy chains allow
us to expand the borders of
how much methionine oxidation can be
allowed
perfect thank you so much for that
so
uh let's move on to okay here's a
question for you
so are there plans for commercial
release of a larger scale fcrn column
for fractionation as was described for
use in offline analysis like peptide
mapping
sure yes so that's a very good question
so with the current volume of the column
of one mil
um it allows us to do the
re fractionation and analysis in a small
scale but we are for sure also
interested to do this in a larger scale
and so therefore we are currently
working on this but it's not uh that it
will be commercial within the next time
frame
perfect thank you so much for that so
now moving on
moving on to our next question
can we enrich specific mono monoclonal
antibodies glycoforms using fcrn
affinity column and know which specific
glycans are important for fcrn binding
um yeah sure as you have seen on my
slide about
the
glycopattern analysis of different
monoclonal antibodies so they are
separated but they're very close to each
other because glycosylation difference
are not as prominent in binding
difference as they are for fc gamma
receptors and so i think it's in
principle possible to do this if you
just select the edges of
the peak so having the left shoulder
perhaps with a very low glycosylation
pattern and the right shoulder with a
very complex and galactosylated
character exhalation pattern but um our
observation is that the pk difference
are not that huge and so therefore we're
also expecting that the glycorelation
differences
after fractionation will be not that
huge of a of a huge difference
wonderful thank you so much for that
so are moving on does debitation impact
fcrn binding
we have tested some of this and
the asparagines in the fc part are not
so directly correlated to fcn binding
so if there is a broader structural
difference then i think we will see it
but you need to have a lot of demutation
and as i said it's not directly
correlated in the binding site
and so therefore we have never observed
the high criticality of
dmitation as we have seen it for
oxidation
okay
we want to thank the audience for all of
these great questions coming in and we
just want to remind you any questions
that we are unable to answer today and
those that come in during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
so
tell me our next question how do you
determine
when to use the fcrn column versus spr
yeah it's it's part of the history that
we have started to use spr essays all
the time so they are are in place and so
therefore there was the beginning of our
escalation scheme that we measure first
spr
for a new antibody but this is now
overcome by the availability of the fcn
column so now it's in place and due to
the point that it's also supplied for us
from a custom biotech we are using
now
90 the fcn column for our open question
because we have seen the benefit
correlated to the sbr data and so
perhaps it could be that we have a data
set starting with spr but we are
shifting over to fcn column as much as
possible and it's now also included in
our screening process in our screening
process we are just using fcm column and
no spr anymore and there could be that
there are some comparability exercises
where we have both but it's going over
more more to the usage of fc and column
in our hands
great thank you so much tillman
so our next questions
and ex and excuse me if i print if i
pronounce this incorrectly but in the
instructions for the column it
recommends using a gradient from twenty
percent b to a hundred percent b
why is this chosen and instead of
altering the a buffer and go from zero
to a hundred percent
just about the starting ph and um this
has been developed over time
that this is the best to prepare the
antibody binding that every molecules
are bound to as you run on the column by
choosing this buffer system and then
applying the gradient that we have a
really sharp illusion profile from the
20 to the 80
and
this was just the the
experience over time
we have adapted sometimes the gradient
for certain purposes but now we have
really standardized this to compare
different antibody constructs by this
fixed gradient that we'd have the
relative retention time evaluation that
we can compare this value to each other
if we modify the ph gradient again then
we are not able to do this
but for a certain perspective for
research it's definitely possible to do
but having this as a standardized method
we prefer to have the fixed buffer
conditions
wonderful thank you for your insight on
that question
now moving on
have you done any experiments to
correlate sub fractions an antibody to
its biological activity such as cdc
adcc
etc
a very great question so for sure yeah
we have done this we have
collected
a fraction of the methyl oxidation and
have studied them
in fc gamma r2 a binding and
adcp assay so it's the antibody
dependent cell phagocytosis
and there is also the ft gamma r2a
receptor involved and we have published
this also in 2017
in collaboration with florian simmer so
i can send around this publication later
wonderful and now tillman do you also
offer fc gamma receptor columns
we are working on this yes
but not not it's not on the market
currently so we have a very good working
system
but it's in the research states
well we will look forward to that coming
out
so our next question
the max flow rate can lower
the max flow rate can lower flow rates
be optimized
and is there any optimization of flow
rate required or beneficial
yeah for sure to reduce the analyst time
so currently it's a low pressure
liquid chromatography system and so the
run time is around 100 minutes
and um
you can easily lower down the flow rate
from the recommended from the
instruction of use
but increasing the flow rate would
result in a higher pressure in the
system you can play around a little bit
with that but we are working on
a solution on this
modifying the scm material that we're
using and modifying the system that we
are going over to an hpl system but this
is also a current development that is
ongoing
and now have you used the column in a qc
or qa stability study
and how did the column help in this
study
yeah
it's not me directly because
i'm coming from non-gmp research
but the colleagues in the controlled
environment are using this so as you see
from the one publication that is used in
yet you can qualify the essay
and we are using this more more for late
comparability exercises so it has very
shown his
benefit of usage for the late stage
colleague and it's possible to use it in
the controlled environment but it's not
validated anymore in in the moment but
as it is product um now you can do this
and i think the future will will prove
this
great thank you so much
so now what types of antibodies have you
tested with the fcrn column beyond you
know igg
what about ige or igm
so we have tested in the beginning also
an ige but it was more or less a
negative control that we can ensure that
it's not binding to
the fcn column matrix
um
for an igm
i don't think that we would see a
retention time we're most interested in
the different igg subclasses like it one
two three and four
because they are described to being able
to bind fcrm and in addition to that we
have studied in the albumin direction
because this is also mentioned to be a
ph dependent binder to scn
and so the other isotypes we have
investigated them indirectly because we
are used um a serum igg preparation
where they also be included
and
in this whole
um serum igg
there is every antibody that is in the
blood circulation and we only have seen
the typical igg's and not all the other
sub
types
thank you
so
do hyper galactosylated variants have a
higher fcrn binding compared to hypo
galacto galactosylated variants
um
yeah so we have seen that we have uh in
vitro glyco-engineered control that is
more or less 95 galactic related
there we have seen a later retention
time compared to the non-galactic
related species or or controls
um
but the effect is more prominent on fc
gamma receptor columns or on ac gamma
receptor assays so we have just seen
that there must be a structural
correlation of the fc
due to the glycopattern that the amino
acids are a little bit other orientated
for the binding site so we've seen
just minor influences on this
and correlated to one question in the
beginning
that
there is a small impact but it's not as
prominent
perfect thank you
so now can you explain the use of the
column and relating to antibody
half-life
yes as
we have seen in the slides um
that there was a clear correlation to
the antibody half-life of real kinema
and
in correlation tools the kinema
and the retention times directly
correlated to the individual half-life
we have seen the correlation for the yte
engineering and
the evil half-life in the human fcn
transgenic mice
and we have really been able to
correlate all the observations from the
different modifications like refined
oxidation engineering and subcharge
features to being correlated to the fcn
potential time
so
but despite this so it's it's a little
bit hard to really predict the exact
half line so we can really predict the
direction so it can say that if there is
an antibody like reaching up and we see
this late non-ph dependent retention
time that we can really say this
antibody will have a bad half life
wonderful and now will this work with
fab fragments
um yeah that was also a data set in this
light set uh the fat alone
is not able to have a strong enough
interaction that's just depending on
charge or hydrophobic patches and so
therefore this interaction is not really
strong for fcm binding it's just the
combination of the fc plus the sub
interaction that makes antibody binding
stronger but the separation of the fc
and the sub was quite interesting for us
to see
the binding strength is mediated by the
ac and then there is an addition from
the top but the pub itself does not find
srm
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
so tillman have you used the column in
an aggregation study
and how did the column help in this
study
oh yes it was really also the question
in the beginning because we had a huge
problem with with interpreting a bash
that had a high aggregation content
and yeah so it was just that we had the
observation do we allow this patch or
not and what is the reason behind this
because the aggregated samples or the
aggregated species
in the sample was really causing a lot
of different interaction on an sbr setup
for example
and we have seen that the five or six
percent of aggregation levels really
overcrowded the data set we had with spr
that we have not really the view on this
sample how to interpret this in the
correct way for predicting a half-life
and applying the fcn column to it we was
able to really see the percentage of
modification we have seen that there is
still
95 percent of monomeric antibodies that
bind as usual to suvn and only the six
percent
um aggregation that eludes later on on
the fcn column and we was able to really
say
this is the root cause of the
aggregation that you have a high leak
binding that overlays any binding
interpretation in an sbr setup and the
column was in this perspective very
beneficial to have
wonderful and you know what let's go
ahead and squeeze one more question in
so you mentioned heparin collins
how do fcrn and heparin columns bindings
relate
this is exactly to understand the
mechanism behind so i had the cartoon
about the antibody pinocytosis and
recycling mechanism in the end as well
going recycled back to the cell surface
again
and there are charge involved and you
can imagine that an antibody subcharge
sees first the glycocalyx of a cell
membrane and it will be interacting with
that and perhaps therefore the
pinocytosis by a charged antibody will
be faster compared an antibody with a
positive or
with a with a
positive charge pattern
and
so seeing that the speed of pinocytosis
is increased and then also correlate to
the combined hub and fc fcn binding
brings us to the point that we need to
have also an observation on this step
and therefore we have used
also a heparin column to
get behind the influence of the
pinocytosis uptake due to the charges
and then to see the combination of this
uptake with fcn recycling
and therefore we have used now a
combination of two columns having a
hyper ring column and then having the
fcm retention time that provides us the
full picture that we need to have
thank you tillman for answering all of
those all of those questions from our
audience do you have any final comments
for our audience before we go
yeah thank you for all the interesting
questions also the question directed to
a new column developments so we are
definitely on this but
it's as usual that it takes some time to
make this really a product and so
therefore i'm glad to interact with
custom biotech that we are able to do
this and also to benefit by ourselves
from the standardized qualified products
that we have now enhance and for sure we
hope that we will get new column types
in the near future
wonderful thank you so much so before we
go we would like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
we would like to once again thank
tillman for his time today and his
important research we would also like to
thank labbert and our sponsor roche
custom biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you everyone
for joining us and until next time
bye-bye
thank you bye
you